okay so we are back with the Incredible
Hulk and it's kind of cool because we
did like the whole World War Hulk you
know Planet Hulk all that stuff we did
all that stuff and honestly I kind of
got burned out by the time I was done I
intended to come back like after taking
a break I intended to come back and
finish this out but it was like a
spider-man announcement and like a
litany of other things that we ended up
covering instead plus there was you know
a lot of the only while different Marvel
stories were proving to be really
popular at that point in time anyway but
we have this for our whole thing like we
have our classic DC day like every
Saturday we cover classic DC stuff we
were doing Green Lantern we put that on
hold to get people caught up with Batman
because I got so many questions then
Wonder Woman came out and now we're
going back to Green Lantern on Saturdays
but for Marvel only wonderful Marvel is
proving itself to not be very popular so
we're covering a bunch of the older
stuff kind of getting caught back up
with the Incredible Hulk getting caught
up before after done with the Incredible
Hulk we'll jump back into spider-man
again we'll get caught back up with
everything after the events of a
superior spider-man and then we're going
to jump into the x-men and of course
this will run all the way to you know
generations when Marvel does a little
thing in the fall and then Thor and all
I kind of get stuff but we'll cross that
bridge when we get to it for right now
we are focusing on the Incredible Hulk
now here's the deal the last part really
the last video that we did brought an
end to Greg packs huge epic run where
was everything from Planet Hulk all the
way up until you know when it was the
end of you know heart of the monster
hole and the last that we saw banner and
Hulk had just kind of jumped out into
the sunset they had race off at red
she-hulk and that was really I mean you
know who is Bruce Banner and Betty Ross
just kind of living together happily
ever after that kind of a thing what
this does is it picks up some point in
time after that we don't really know
exactly how long after that we just know
it picks up after that and the idea here
is that the Incredible Hulk is basically
just kind of living underground doing
his own thing and it's really kind of
cool because he lives with the Malloys
now of course some alloys are basically
these little henchmen of The Mole Man
but they evolved you know from their own
thing if I remember correctly Jonathan
Hickman kind of retold our origin and
said they were a byproduct of the High
Evolutionary experimenting on various
things but the fact remains that
basically they dwell underground that's
really their whole thing they stay
underground and there's there's millions
of them all across the world the fact
remains here Incredible Hulk stays here
because of the fact that this is peace
this is how he knows peace you know it's
a way for him to exist outside the realm
of humanity which really kind of begs
the question why didn't he do anything
like this before but the other
half of this scenario is really kind of
begging the question what happened to
Bruce Banner because the Incredible Hulk
keeps telling us things about how
banners not there anymore
banners gone the banner and Hulk are
basically separated now this also comes
by way of the introduction of a woman
named Amanda Von Doom now the funny
thing about this is my initial reaction
was if this is a man of on doom does
that make her the daughter of Victor Von
Doom that's never really explained all
we're really told at least as was given
to us is that there's no relation
between her and Victor Von Doom and
that's really it it seems like it was an
idea that was going to be fleshed out
but ultimately it wasn't just because
this is a really short run I mean this
is like a like a 12 issue run of The
Incredible Hulk and then it was canceled
and relaunched because really after Greg
Koch run nobody was really buying it
because he incredible hope just really
couldn't sell and there were too many
things going on too many stories
happening in Marvel at the time and this
one just kind of got overlooked which is
sort of disappointing because it's so
good but all we end up finding out is
that Amanda Von Doom is here because of
the fact that Bruce Banner has
effectively lost his mind and so what
this confirms is that Bruce Banner in
the Incredible Hulk had been split into
two different people and we don't know
how we have no real idea how that's
happened but what we do know is that
Bruce Banner is obsessed with the idea
of regaining the Incredible Hulk and
what he's done is he's taken up
residence on an island and he's begun
experimenting with the indigenous life
on that island turning them all into
Hulk's more or less and so there's whole
pigs and there's full Tigers all I kind
of stuff it's the island of a thousand
hooks it's absolutely crazy in terms of
all the things that are there now of
course with the arrival of you know
Amanda what this does is it jumps back
to the aftermath of Greg Cox Run which
basically kind of fills in the holes a
little bit what we find out is that
we're a burst banner and Betty Ross you
know we're the Incredible Hulk in red
she-hulk that basically just kind of
raced off to go do their own thing that
ultimately they ended up splitting up
just because of the fact that Bruce
Banner you know once he was separated
from The Incredible Hulk tried to make a
life for himself now Betty Ross under
the mantle of red she-hulk tried to live
this life with him because remember they
were really kind of married I mean their
their marriage never officially came to
an end I mean she was dead but it wasn't
officially annulled and so because of
this it's been basically trying to start
their life all over again the problem
with this is that Bruce brought Betty
here for a couple reasons one was to you
know for the two of them to enjoy their
life and two was because of the fact
that this island has gamma radiation
exposure and so he's trying to you know
kill two birds with one stone one we
gain
the Incredible Hulk or he'll bring the
Incredible Hulk back and to try to enjoy
his life at Betty Ross of course this
leads to the two of them really kind of
going their own separate ways and it's
really important thing to hit home here
Betty Ross makes a passing statement it
really kind of makes an argument to
Bruce Banner of whether or not he was
the monster or the Hulk was the monster
and that's a very important theme
throughout this story because what we're
going to find out is that Bruce Banner
is actually a very dark guy more so than
that what this story also highlights is
the relationship between Bruce and the
Hulk and again we'll get to that you
know here in a little bit in terms of
Amanda Von Doom she functions as a
member of a group called the mad squad
and they're just one of these small
ancillary groups
it's contracted by the government that
serves a purpose of just finding and
tracking down mad scientist I mean it's
really just kind of like a new
introduction this designed only for this
because as far as I'm aware
Amanda Von Doom never appears in
anything outside of the Incredible Hulk
she appears in this run and then she's
never seen or heard from again and
that's it like that's the end of her
character she's basically gone forever
but what she basically tells the
Incredible Hulk
is look we don't know what happened
between you and Banner we don't really
know what took place the whole kind of
vaguely you know draws the idea that
somebody was the one who split them up
that Hulk was the one that came up with
the idea in the first place for the two
of them to split but the idea here is
basically that Bruce banners been
experimenting on this life he's really
kind of lost his mind and the idea is to
go find him and bring him in it's really
at this point he's really just like a
contract for the mad squad and that's
really in I mean that's the extension of
it it's not some higher purpose it's not
like Nick Fury called them in or
anything like that it's just dirt
they're contracted by the government to
bring banner in and that's really yet
what we end up doing here is we find out
the length at which Banner is gone and
going through and kind of transforming
each day for example they run into an
Incredible Hulk version of a great white
shark now I got to tell you guys this is
absolutely horrifying
like a great white shark that's been
mutated and increased in size and
durability and strength by gamma
radiation it's absolutely terrifying
it's like a Megalodon shark now of
course the Hulk and everybody is able to
you know make their way ashore and
that's really the end of that but the
other half of this is that Hulk doesn't
really have much of an intention to
basically track down Banner the initial
response of him was no it's not my
problem what Banner does is none of my
concern and his intention was to
originally leave it was the basically
just walk away and leave Amanda Von Doom
and her guys to do whatever it is that
they end up doing
let into the ship basically being
attacked and then you know somewhat
capsizing we're the very least knocking
them off and that was really the end of
that what we end up finding out is
because the fact that banner is
continuing to try to experiment on the
indigenous life in and around that
island because for the most part all
other animals have basically been used
up he sends his guys in you know
underground and they start grabbing up
some of the Malloys so again what this
does is it brings the Incredible Hulk in
because now he has a vested interest in
stopping banner because his family so to
speak has been kidnapped by banner now
of course once we end up getting back
you know once we follow the Incredible
Hulk back to his lair he basically finds
out he has a partner that a couple of
these guys have run off with the young
members of the Malloys The Incredible
Hulk tracks them down and it leads to a
pretty epic battle and again that's one
of the cool things about this is because
Jason Aaron is trying on this version of
The Incredible Hulk this is not world
breaker but the idea has always been
that the Incredible Hulk is at is
strongest under one of two circumstances
either Bruce Banner and the Incredible
Hulk
have a common interest and they carry
out that interest or Bruce Banner is
separated from the Incredible Hulk
but the common theme between these two
things as that Bruce Banner relinquishes
his subconscious control over the Hulk
that was the common theme among these
things that for example back during the
onslaught saga when onslaught was this
omnipotent being there was virtually
indestructible nobody could stop him
nobody could bring his reign to an end
we ended up having a Jean Grey really
kind of like repress or I guess suppress
the entire Bruce Banner personality
before eventually of splitting him away
which allowed Savage Hall to emerge The
Incredible Hulk with all his unbridled
rage and unbridled power without the
influence of Bruce Banner with world
breaker Hulk it was the two of them kind
of acting in tandem Banner found
happiness through the Incredible Hulk
happiness but I was ultimately stripped
away when the ship of the Illuminati
simply Hulk on ended up exploding
killing everything that he knew and
loved and so again it really hits home
at the idea but the Incredible Hulk is
at is strongest when Banner is not
subconsciously trying to relinquish his
control now in this instance again what
kind 20-round with different things here
because when Bruce Banner was removed
from the Incredible Hulk we've seen
different reactions we see me Incredible
Hulk incredibly powerful but nowhere
near his world breaker Hulk form now I
went in to keep in line is that in
relation to the world war hulk event and
in relation to his world breaker Hulk
form that's the angriest he's ever been
he's never been angry er than that at
this point he's not blood
right I mean he's not lost his rational
thinking he's not totally out of his
mind you know he's just really really
really really strong so again it's kind
of cool to see this battle with him and
yoli's few henchmen of Bruce Banner
because the impact the punches the
shockwaves stretch off the island into
the main city itself into the mainland
so it really kind of shows us what kind
of power we're dealing with and so what
is I'm happening as of course Amanda Von
Doom and her forces basically go on the
island itself with the intention of
taking down Bruce Banner and of course
the incredible hope joins them after
defeating these couple hits from a
banner just because of the fact that at
this point Banner is going after the
family quote/unquote of the Incredible
Hulk which again now gives the
Incredible Hulk a vested interest in
trying to stop Bruce Banner now once
they actually reach the island proper
and once they end up going against these
various forces again almost everything
is a version of the Incredible Hulk
there's an incredible tiger and
incredible hope gorilla all the
indigenous life on this island have all
been walked out but all of this is done
by Bruce Banner for the purpose of
trying to find a way to basically
duplicate or recreate the Incredible
Hulk now this eventually leads to being
credible confronting Banner and this is
when we really start to get into the
nature of the zoo characters and that's
the coolest thing about this is because
for years and years and years even
banner doesn't really know what goes on
with the Incredible Hulk but for years
and years and years it was believed that
with Bruce banners you know his origin
being retold in the sense that he was
the child of an abusive father that all
the anger and all the rage that he had
felt you know the helpless as he had
experienced under the abusive regime of
his father manifested in coalesced into
be Incredible Hulk personality and it
wasn't until Bruce Banner was first
exposed to the gamma bomb that the
Incredible Hulk actually stopped being
just sort of the psychological
coalescence of anger and rage and took
on a physical form in the form of the
Hulk and Banner even experiments with
that man or even says well I mean that
kind of seems to be the case you know I
don't even fully understand the
relationship between the two of us but
what does also seems to hint out with
the two of them being basically split
apart is that they are two distinct
personalities they're totally separate
from one another they can exist without
the other
now again this is not the first time
we've seen this but it's the first time
that a writer has really emphasized and
focused on this notion in terms of how
to to view one another the other half of
this is that notice Bruce Banner is
insane Bruce banners absolutely lost his
mind and he's crazy be incredible whole
is the rational
and so again this really kind of begged
some interesting questions especially
when we get into the idea of who it was
that split the two of them apart but of
course with Bruce Banner using what
little surprise that he has at his
disposal and kind of incapacitating the
Hulk only for a fraction of a second I
mean the whole thing almost immediately
recovers this begins to get into the
idea of who it was that split the two of
them apart and so what we do is we
actually jump to about a few weeks
before this story took place and we
actually had the Incredible Hulk
arriving at the lair of Victor Von Doom
of Doctor Doom and this is kind of a
crazy scenario because the incredible
hope goes to him and says look I just
want myself in banner to be split apart
now of course the funny thing about this
is we actually end up finding out the
Incredible Hulk went to several people
before he went to dr. doom and that
makes sense because dr. doom is pretty
nefarious I mean he's really kind of a
bad guy you know it's one of these
things where his help always comes with
a price there's no such thing as Doctor
Doom doing something for free there's no
such thing as a free lunch somebody
somewhere is paying for this is the
whole idea is that doom says yes I will
help you but my help will come at a
price I will ask you for something and
you're going to have to give it to me
now the genius thing about what it is
that Jason Aaron does with this little
tidbit of a story is he immediately
answers the question how in the world do
you make Bruce Banner in the Incredible
Hulk two distinctly different people
because they're the same person
Bruce Banner loses control of whatever
it is in the Incredible Hulk emerges
Bruce banners body physically changes
and becomes the Incredible Hulk but they
both share the same brain it was like
how do you split somebody apart like
that that's the beauty of all this
because of the fact that Bruce Banner
and the Incredible Hulk
share the same body you can't split
their physical form that's not going to
happen that's so because of that the
incredible Hulk's body as it exists
right now is effectively Bruce banners
normal for I'm sorry Bruce banners body
it's just it's in the form of B
Incredible Hulk at the moment and so
what what dr. doom did is he removed the
brain of the Incredible Hulk just took
it out in its entirety and then created
a new body that was basically a clone of
Bruce Banner and then he took that brain
any put it in Bruce banners body and
then he in turn engineered a second
brain just created a brain and then
threw it inside the incredible Hawks
head and so again it's a pretty genius
idea and so Bruce Banner is just as
smart as he ever was mean credible Hulk
is just kind of average I mean he's a
reasonably smart guy but what this does
is it answers the question why the
Incredible Hulk is so intelligent or at
least you know more intelligent than he
normally is why you
not a mindless beast why he's not all
smash you know and so on and so forth
because he's got the brain of an average
person inside his head he's a reasonable
thinking person he's you he's me is
anybody else out there and so again it's
really kind of cool because it creates
this whole you know scenario with
regards to why the Hulk is you know able
to think rationally a great way to kind
of tie up and answer a lot of these
questions that were kind of lingering
from the time this story started really
up until this moment but the problem
with this and really kind of the funny
scenario is that we end up having the
Incredible Hulk of course overpowering
Bruce Banner only for Bruce Banner to
basically reveal that hey look I
basically put gamma bombs inside trees
all around this island because the
insanity of Bruce Banner had basically
led him to the mindset that's a goal was
to basically recreate the original gamma
bomb experiment that manifested The
Incredible Hulk
in the first place now of course we know
that's not going to happen because
there's nothing in his body to bring the
Incredible Hulk forward there's no
hidden gene there's no nothing there
it's just be incredible hoaxes totally
separate if a gamma bomb went off Bruce
Banner would just die that's the only
thing that would happen the other half
of this is that we end up finding out
that various people that have been taken
by Bruce Banner have been subjected to
gamma radiation and they have turned
into these Hulk like beings but they're
not the Incredible Hulk they're cheap
knockoffs they're not nearly as strong
not nearly as durable they're just not
on the same level now of course again
jumping back to this moment with Doctor
Doom kind of jumping back to the past
for a second we end up finding out that
dr. Doom's requests the favor that he
asked was that he wanted Bruce Banner he
wanted the body of Bruce Banner now what
he was going to use it for
we have no earthly clue we have no real
idea if you were just going to make
Bruce Banner exist as a slave which
seems to really be the implication or if
he was going to switch minds with Bruce
Banner we have no real idea what his
motivation was or we know that there was
a little bit of a hesitation with the
Incredible Hulk in terms of letting this
happen so the Incredible Hulk basically
stepped in and brought down you know
basically took up Reese Tanner's body
and whisked him away and that's the
reason why Bruce Banner is free and out
on this island is because the whole
basically rescued him from Doctor Doom
which again it's kind of a cool little
moment here but ultimately you know back
in this moment right now in this fight
between Banner and this fight between
the Incredible Hulk it's basically a
no-win situation The Incredible Hulk is
durable The Incredible Hulk can
withstand nuclear explosions the bombs
of Bruce Banner are being set off by
Amanda Von Doom you know the idea of
basically trying to find a way that if
they can't capture Bruce Banner then
they can kill him and call it
they can still fulfill their contract by
eliminating Bruce Banner so of course
where banner tries to run away The
Incredible Hulk keeps him there The
Incredible Hulk doesn't let him leave
key allows Bruce Banner to die and so
what this does is it basically sets off
this massive explosion and Bruce Banner
is essentially killed and again that's
kind of mind-blowing here because now
Bruce Banner is dead he's no longer part
of the equation and again this that's
kind of a crazy scenario because I never
expected that to happen nobody ever
really did in my mind I expected the
situation unfold in the sense that we
would just kind of see Bruce Banner
absorbed back into the Incredible Hulk
almost immediately
anyone allowed the two of them to go
forward which begs the question how does
Bruce Banner end up coming back later on
now of course from here this is
basically the idea of Jason Aaron kind
of wrapping up the madness of Bruce
Banner and the reason why I say that is
because of the fact that once it's all
said and done the Incredible Hulk goes
back to Victor Von Doom he goes back to
Doctor Doom and says what could you do
to banner
what did you do to make him so insane
what did you do to make him so crazy now
this is actually really really cool and
this is a great moment here because we
me Incredible Hulk looks at Bruce Banner
and even when the Incredible when when
Banner was the one walking around and
The Incredible Hulk was the receipted
personality The Incredible Hulk was
still relatively aware even if not on a
cognitive level he was so relatively
aware of some of the things that that it
was doing or the very least he had a
good enough understanding a banner to
know what he was about and banner was by
no means a crazy person he wasn't nearly
as crazy as we saw him in that story it
was very out of character for him and
that was one of the big things that I
initially kind of came upon I was like
what seems kind of weird the banner
would be that far out there because he's
not normally that crazy that was kind of
cool because Jason Aaron could have just
left it that way but we comes back and
he basically answers that he gives us
that discussion and that's what makes
him such a great writer because some
writers would've just left it that way
and what I just said yeah I mean he just
kind of lost his mind
which begs the question well why was the
character so out of character in the
first place why was banner so crazy at
all now the response to the Incredible
Hulk is to believe that dr. doom had
done something to Bruce Banner
he had done something to mess with him
he had done something to screw up his
head to make him run awry but dr. Doom's
responses I didn't do anything like
maybe it was always just you that kept
him in check maybe it was the fact that
you kept him company maybe it was the
fact that you were a physical
manifestation of all the rage and all
the anger that he had ever experienced
as we knew but no matter what happened
you would always come back and you would
always have his back as much as he hated
you he
needed you psychologically physically he
needed the Incredible Hulk because in
his heart of hearts when it all came
down to it first bana was not some
rational scientist he was not some guy
that had it all together he was a guy
who was just experiencing unbridled
unchecked rage fully his whole treatment
at the hands of his father and instead
of all that rage being able to coalesce
and manifest in the into the Incredible
Hulk and just kind of basically being a
vent for all the rage that Bruce Banner
was constantly feeling instead it all
started bubbling up and it started
driving him crazy
because with Bruce Banner having been
the victim of an abusive father to that
anger that rage that hatred that
resentment that never goes away it stays
with you forever and so because of that
it's really kind of an interesting
scenario because what it does is it
presents the possibility that this
constant anger that Bruce Banner had
towards his dad basically allowed itself
to be vented through the Incredible Hulk
whenever the Incredible Hulk was
fighting bad guys when everything
Incredible Hulk was fighting alongside
the earth superheroes
whenever the Incredible Hulk was
fighting will Draenor he was fighting
Deadpool the events of World War fo
Planet Hulk it allowed Bruce Banner to
vent all that frustration and event all
that anger which gives us an explanation
of stories like world war hawk the whole
didn't worked in tandem because one
Bruce Banner was angry about losing his
happiness but two it allowed him to vent
all that anger that all that frustration
towards his dad but as soon as the
Incredible Hulk is gone there's no way
to vent that anger
there's no Incredible Hulk that will
allow banner to cut loose and so all
that anger all that rage all that
resentment all that hatred just kind of
builds up in at coalescence and it
drives banner absolutely insane because
there's no out
there's no way to let it go and so again
it's really really disagree real because
it really kind of hits home for a lot of
us when we've been down that where we've
experienced like kind of abusive
situation so it's really kind of a cool
scenario with regards to three
characters now of course this inevitably
leads to dr. doom just kind of
overpowering The Incredible Hulk and
calling it a day
but it also sets the stage for the
Incredible Hulk returning back to the
island they really kind of paying his
last dudes you know really kind of
paying his last moment such a banner
really kind of burying him so to speak
released what slash because at this
point it's just pile of ashes but we
also really also end up finding out that
a man hook on doom had taken several of
these multiplied people and beings and
so on they were created by banner and
which them aboard her own ship for
whatever purpose it is does she has plan
we don't really know what the purpose is
we simply just know that it's there but
without being said guys
you are new here to come as explained
which you guys with the sub button to
become part of the rod port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah let me know if you guys
want to see more incredible hook stuff
and I'll catch you all later peace
[Music]